we do have the ultimate celebrity
psychosis I hope you are all ready for
this oh man
comrade Britney Spears comrade Britney
just the fact that they call her comrade
Britney Spears comrade Spears comrade
Spears calls for wealth redistribution
general strike amid coronavirus pandemic
okay if you're a celebrity and you want
to come out and say something dumb I'm
going to make fun of you and here's how
you do it but hold on Britney no no no
no holes I'm showing us but if you're a
communist and you take something dumb I
will especially you now if you combine
all of those things and you're a
celebrity she's not really a communist
that's being mean but she is going
pretty commie I guess yeah it you know
look already I can hear the the
screaming hordes of lefties being like
they're not real communists well I know
they're not real communists calm down
I'm making fun of her they're calling
her comrade Britain in the article
that's the joke I also have notice I
noticed that the amid it's going around
everyone's using this word a minute I
know it's in every news yeah everything
right it's hilarious the word because
we're in the midst in the midst of it of
a crowd of I don't know that's the next
one that's to come and install right
here we go here we go you ready for this
instead of just give me more she wants
to give everyone more Oh comrade Britney
Spears shed an Instagram post Monday
calling for wealth redistribution and a
general strike either during or
following the krona virus pandemic Oh
hold on oh my gosh well I'm gonna read
this this post but can I just say the
last thing we needed a general strike
the economy is yeah who's gonna strike
the only people working are the
essentials desperately please don't
strike we need you to work your paper
and you're doing a great job we
appreciate you everyone's already out of
work yeah if we put people back to work
and they went and start striking the
economy would keep going down wouldn't
it just be time to turn that around
yeah well sr here's what Britney Spears
said two or twenty three point six
million followers during this time of
isolation we need connection now more
than ever call your loved ones right
virtual love letters technologies like
virtual communication streaming and
broadcasting are part of our community
collaboration we will learn to kiss and
hold each other through the waves of the
web we will feed each other
redistribute wealth strike that that's
very strange turn yeah it's just like
wow it actually wasn't that bad until
that like wait a minute
we will understand our own importance
from the places we must stay communion
moves beyond walls we can still be
together
Mimi's ooh who's Mimi's ooh yeah you
know it's weird it's like it's like the
bill they're trying to pass it's a good
but then yeah then there have this like
sentence dude this whole big chunk you
gave me riled up sorry start no no no
don't get riled up I'm sorry my bad
sorry
let's I'm a backpedal back no no no no
no no no floodgates have been lifted
they say the singer reposted the text
originally shared by user Mimi Xue which
read in part we will feed each other
redistribute wealth strike we will
understand our own importance in the
places we must stay Spears 38 caption
the post communion goes beyond walls
with three red rose emojis that emoji is
also commonly used by Democratic
socialists America yep the Rose symbol
period is the socialist symbol yeah so
it's the two hands shaking and there's a
rose behind it it's the socialist okay
right one commenter called spears the
queen of proletariat while another
dubbed her queen of communion and
communism
who knew toxic was really about
capitalism so let's let's see we can
pull up some of these some of these
comments here look at this one of them
was general strike oh you know I can't
read any this is just people here we go
redistribute wealth is key right now oh
man queen of post capitalism love you
Britney oh and then people are tagging
the other person so I'll tell you what
man this is exactly this is a really
good example of of what they've been
doing with these bills for a long time
you brought it up so I'm gonna say it
yeah but check it out let's see it's
pretty blaring to me that right now so I
don't know where
we're right so far maybe they agreed on
a bill or something that voting knows I
mean I'm sure the people in the comments
will probably clarify for us yeah but
for for a week the Republicans were
working on a bill and apparently that
negotiated it and then at the last
minute when it came to vote the
Democrats struck it down and then they
came back with this bill and here's what
really bothers me all of these news
outlets they were ported on it as though
the Democrats want to give you $3,000 a
month but the Republicans only want to
give you $1,200 one time and I'm like
that's not the complaint from the
Republicans the complaint is that in the
middle of it is this like we want a hug
and love everyone and communism and then
we're gonna be great friends for that
some of our lives and strike and make a
bunch of money you give it a right yeah
so it's like it's it's it's they're
saying the quiet part and that's exactly
what this post you know it's a it's like
it it comes it starts off with people
being like oh yeah that's so great and
then right in the middle I'll keep I'll
keep reading and yeah sure that was
great and then I'll share it without
really understanding what that sentence
means right many times this was shared
and the other funny thing too is like
we're gonna kiss and hold each other
through the waves of the web also
communism is it yeah that sounds a
little idealistic so that would be what
I would expect from someone who likes
coming this is just but I don't think
she knows what she's talking about
there's I'll tell you I'll tell you
exactly what's happening with the with
these celebrities with social media
they're chasing each other off a cliff
constantly wanting up one-upping each
other trying to be the next shock wave
so yeah I'll just say all of these
celebrities all of their posts and
especially Britney Spears is it's the
equivalent of looking at toilet seat
it's the celebrity toilet it's it's it's
the yeah toileting challenge yeah so
what ends up happening is here's here's
what here's what I think
regular people aren't on social media
right right there off minding their own
business working or whatever most most
Americans are not on Twitter at the time
so you get someone like Britney Spears
and she's watching everyone say stuff so
then she jumps in but has to one-up
everything that's been said before
and then someone sees her hurt you know
23 million followers and so they have to
start from where she is and one-up her
now her at the point where celebrities
are like redistribute wealth yeah
you're like what does that have to do
with York pop capitalism music I don't
see any other celebrities to call now
for redistribution of wealth just
Britney Spears there's a decent amount
oh is there I mean it's not just that
it's like Madonna once said that she I
can't even repeat what you said oh
really she was at a rally in DC and said
something about let me just put it this
way she wanted to cause physical harm to
the White House she was doing slam
poetry about and then she said oh no I
actually was speaking figuratively I
didn't mean it literally it was
something along the lines of that
offspring song that suddenly disappeared
yeah a little bit yeah
yeah right worse than that yes oh my an
awful lot so I will mention that to many
many people might not know this but punk
rock band The Offspring have a song from
their self-titled album and I can't say
the name that song yeah and they
actually got rid of it yeah I don't and
it's kind of crazy cuz it's like I have
that album somewhere too in my stuff
bring it out listen to that so where do
you wait if it's still on there we
should take bets on like where you think
the next celebrity is gonna go you know
what I mean like to one-up Britney here
so so so here's what I think is
happening it's not just their one-upping
each other it's that the people who have
no lives like you've got these really
weird socialist people they're obviously
not working it's probably why they're
socialists or there's some kind of
correlation and so this thing of the
Internet's spamming away and saying
nonsensical garbage yeah
so you know you tweet more you're more
likely to be seen right so all of a
sudden people like Britney they go on
Twitter and what do they see waves and
waves of socialists because those are
the ones who have no jobs who spend all
their time on the Internet mm-hmm then
she and all these other celebrities are
like that's what people like ooh
socialism so where's what's what's the
next thing I mean you see all this
tumblr stuff it's like weird stuff I
don't think I've ever been on tumblr I
don't know you know tumblr gender is I
don't know if I really want to know no
no it's like but like on a guest where
all this stuff comes from
really so there's like a tumblr yeah
there's like a list of a pictures or
something no dogs it's like Oh text post
pictures what am I thinking of then
what's the only pictures Instagram
I thought tumblr was just a bunch of
pictures that people like pin or
something so for so I don't know
anything about something like
multi-gender stuff yeah there's there's
a list of I think like two or three
thousand genders three thousand thousand
genders thousands of genders yeah Wow
there's funny ones there's like my
favorite was hydro gender hydro hydro
gender it says a gender that's fluid
like water and I'm just like that
doesn't mean anything
that's not even nothing but I think it
was um she one had you know she has you
know you know you know you know shoe
right I'm familiar
yeah June I've know she's like a big
youtuber and I'm pretty sure was her and
I think our Mertz got I did it both
youtubers UK and they went through the
list of like thousands of genders oh
really
just reading them just reading them and
that was entertainment content to like
I'll tell you what man there's like some
of it makes no sense yeah so there's not
that we're getting into it I guess like
New York for instance has 31 recognized
genders and some of them are the exact
same really
but this I'll bring this up because it
kind of it kind of like we're creating a
path here from Britney Spears as being a
communist into the law when these people
go on social media and say this stupid
trash and then other people hear it they
then go demand it and politicians see it
and then go you got it and then enact
tumblr genders as law I saw I saw a
comment someone said its Pinterest
that's what I was thinking of interest
yeah thanks thank you I don't remember
yeah I don't know either one but oh yeah
Pinterest you pin your you Pinterest I
mean yeah but I guess pinches yeah I
don't know tumblr Chris is like their
idea like people run Etsy businesses or
something like they pin photos and then
you click it and you can buy the product
something oh yeah okay sure tumblr is
where everyone everyone has some kind of
neurological disorder and I'm not making
it up they put in there like I was like
I have all of these mental illnesses
what's it called like neuro atypical yes
yes so so here's the thing they're
literally competing to be the most
mentally ill well I'm not exaggerating
and then they say stuff like this and
that's why you see celebrities like
Britney being communist now Wow
interesting goes from tumbler to
celebrities to politicians
it's took to Twitter to celebrities so
so I'll put it this way here's what I
hear it's actually really simple it
there's an economic incentive here
news organizations want to hire
journalists with lots of followers okay
because their their gamble is if you
write a store and you got much followers
you'll tweet it out it'll get traffic
will make money yeah you're more of an
influencer how do you get followers you
like toilet seats yeah I mean I she
didn't the woman who did that didn't get
followers for the most part but right
you do things like that
yeah so these journalists on Twitter
then start creating insane just Luna
lunacy because it attracts people to
follow them just trying to get crazy and
then they can go to a company and say I
got too many thousand followers
Oh yup and then I want to get my
followers the old-fashioned way no just
just by doing the same stuff I do every
day anyway but here's what happens when
the news organizations then start
writing this insane you know
pro-communist stuff mm-hmm
then other celebrities start seeing it
hurts spreading I mean is the daily news
you know what man I'm Britney Britney I
don't I don't know if the daily news
posts like legitimate stuff all the time
but no that means it's true I don't
think Britney Spears knows anything
about wealth redistribution I don't
think she knows what that means
probably she's sitting in some very
expensive you know big room you know and
she's got her iPhone and she's going
like oh my god oh you mean oh yes yes
men around her yes well I think I don't
know if she's still like owned by her
dad or whatever conservatorship or
something like that was the thing that
after she was a teenager or something
when you've got famous or well I don't
know how it works yes you went out the
real interesting do you think there's a
correlation between you know like
Britney Spears being crazy and communism
maybe I love Reagan on communism thanks
for checking out this clip from the Tim
cast IRL podcast we do the show live
Monday through Friday at 8 p.m. if you
want to catch the full show tune in to
this channel subscribe hit the like
button or check us out on iTunes and
Spotify and we will soon have this
podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next
soda
you